what i know of saturday live when it
first came on johnny said i don't mind i
don't mind nbc if you put a night a late
night show on uh but i don't want to be
made fun of that's the only caveat to uh
me allowing this because johnny owned
that time slot so to speak and he's like
the biggest star in the world it's hard
to avoid him yeah you weren't allowed it
wasn't allowed david right i think we
ever got that he he liked it initially
because i would go on i was hot at the
time so i would go on his yearly
anniversary show where he and and sit
with him and then he would show a
montage of my appearances and i did that
for three years in a row
and i and he said you know he's he's
making fun of arsenio as much as he's
making fun of me and he was very good
about it
and then there was one sketch that did
make him come off a little senile i
think that uh susan day was on and
johnny didn't know that the partridge
family hadn't been on in 15 years so is
that a good show for you how's that
david cassidy i mean the girls really
like him and i didn't write that one and
i i did put up a red flag
with lauren and others and they were
like oh please you did johnny'd be fine
but that was it i was never went on the
show again he doesn't say anything to
you you just you never hear from the guy
yeah you just said you just never heard
of him and jay leno had told me that
because of the style of impression i did
because i do believe that everyone
becomes a caricature of themself at some
point
and it was it wasn't the rich little one
who was great but he was just doing
little birdie told me doing the
monologue this was johnny's little
johnny-isms you know somebody told me
you know that kind of guy yeah and um he
would go down the hall at nbc and
burbank and yell out loud they're making
funny fun of me now it's time to go
those sketches were great being there re
seeing a read through and knowing this
one's gonna work really well and
everyone was into them so it was almost
unstoppable and also you got a little
piece that it was working and you go a
little farther and you're like oh this
is even working better so
i think it was inevitable and he was
toward the end and it was he should be
allowed to be made fun of a little bit
but you know well i mean he
yeah i
i love doing that sketch so much and
there was something about it that it was
the only time as a comedian i didn't
care if i got laughs i didn't care i
knew it was too [ __ ] funny it was
like if those you at home you're
watching a thing called a television
we are coming to you with our thing and
you know how he would bring everybody in
i i did not know that is that weird is
that wild so i i just thought it was so
funny and phil was so perfect and it was
just like a perfect sketch i didn't care
if i got laughs
but i did